so are you trying to trigger people
or are you just trying to change
the pattern and make them more present
by not having them know what's coming
next and forcing them into
a different sort of um
mental space like where yeah
i'm not trying to necessarily like
intentionally trigger people
but but but i think when you put people
in a environment of the unfamiliar
and the unknown
naturally
uh
a lot of the unresolved fears and stuff
will tend to rise to the surface that we
have been able to hide and mask
in our tick-tock everyday lives of
routines and habits that we can you know
control
and so
let's let's let me just explain it this
way
it's really you know we're so addicted
and attached to our sense of self as
this ego structure that we believe
ourselves to be i'm cool i'm nina i'm
danica i'm jennifer and this is me and
so we have this very rigid and
tight-holded holding grip on our sense
of
meanness i'm not enough i'm unlovable
i'm a beautiful i'm not this i'm not
that i'm not intelligent
and so with this combination of beliefs
and stories and emotions and patterning
and energetics that we've held onto from
our past we hold on to this
we identify and hold on to this pattern
as a version of ourselves and we think
that this version of ourselves that we
have become is who we really are and the
degree to which we hold on to
that version of danica-ness or cuteness
or john-ness is the degree to which
we're not free to truly
live authentically truly live in the
moment truly be in the now the present
moment because to truly be in and out is
the ability to respond authentically in
the moment to what is arising rather
than from the conditioned unconscious
responses from our past and so as
children
we are shall we say we're born free you
know you look at a child
yeah a child is you know we're alive
right we're you look into a child's eyes
the child is they're in touch with the
divine they're in touch with their
essence and i think that's where when we
look into a child we melt because we are
reminded of our own divinity we're
reminded of what we were once so what
the hell happens you know we were these
bright beings we would jump on a table
and sing and shout and we didn't care if
we didn't sound like you know mariah
carey or bruno mars we ran naked and we
didn't care like i got a few rolls right
uh what do i look like on instagram i'm
not you know slim enough i'm too fat we
were just being letting it all hang out
we pooped when we felt like pooping we
cried when we felt like we were just
being pure
essential light the light that we were
so what the hell happens that begins
this self-contraction the first thing is
we incarnate into this human experience
we meet our parents they're just doing
the best that they can do based on their
upbringing and their conditioning and
their childhood so we're born into kind
of a preset
uh pattern of conditioning based on
parents based on culture society
religion ancestral patterns and
addictions and conditioning that's been
unresolved so now we're born into this
framework that we're convinced into and
maybe
dad was an alcoholic or mom had mental
health issues or maybe they were
fighting all the time so there was or
maybe they were nice people but they
didn't know how to meet our emotional
needs and so now
and that was painful so now there's some
level of dysfunction trauma or pain that
we experience you know as children and
so often unconsciously because with
these sensitive beings two things happen
the first thing is we begin to learn how
to shut down disconnect and not feel
as a way of survival the pain that's
going on around in our environment while
it's really painful to not have my needs
met and that really hurts and i feel
helpless so let me just it's too painful
to feel that so let me just numb that
let me shut that down let me disconnect
and so
the first thing is all of the sort of
unprocessed unfelt suppressed emotions
anger pain hurts see we suppress it we
suppress it we suppress it those layers
begin building up and our true authentic
light our true authentic beingness our
true authentic essence is always there
whether we're aware of it or not it just
kind of gets hidden and clouded
underneath the layers of unprocessed
emotion
and now we're wondering well why do i
feel heavy why do i feel depressed and
so we also start learning
a way of being in the world to a defense
mechanism we erect walls in our heart we
we go into our mind become so overly
analytical disconnect from our feelings
our bodies as a way to again not feel
the pain so that that way of
self-protection that we unconsciously
learn in response to what's going on we
then become that version of ourselves
and we hold tightly to that
version of ourselves to survive
to function and ultimately to never
feel that pain
again
that holding on becomes a
positionality of control
we can call it the ego and we hold on to
that as a way to never feel that pain
again it worked for us when we were five
now we're 10 now we're 20. now we're 25
now we fall in love and our heart opens
and we're like no i'm never gonna i'm
not gonna open my heart so i don't feel
that helpless all that pain again and so
that
self-contraction that we've learned to
become to function and survive we learn
a strategy to get love validation and
approval like who do i need to be in
order to be loved by my dad for me i
thought i needed to be the perfect son
the good one the good boy get all lays
you know take care of everyone take care
of my mother never cry suck it up be
independent and
take over my father's church which we
can get into but but you know we develop
all sorts of roles and masks and
personas
that we present to the world in order to
get love validation and approval so
between avoidance of pain and the
self-defense mechanism that we erect and
the personas of mass that we were we end
up contorting ourselves into a
particular shape we end up controlling
ourselves into a particular condition
construct pattern that we think you see
we are we hold tightly onto that that
gets reinforced by society life those
around us and we end up holding so
tightly to that that there's no freedom
and we end up thinking this is who we
are
we're just basically conditioned with
condition and we hold so tightly and so
we could say that is ego that's what ego
is the sense of what we identify and
perceive ourselves to be
and the degree to which we're
conditioned the degree to which we're
holding on the degree to which we think
that that's what we are
is the degree to which we're not free
we're not free to love and truly be in
the now and respond from what's what's
really there we're not you know so much
of our potential that we feel inside
gets trapped inside of the pattern in
the prison of our conditioning you know
and so and so
that tends to get reinforced by the life
that we live and that's why
when i unplug people from their typical
life that is reinforcing that pattern of
conditioning
it starts
triggering it starts loosening that grip
that we're used to holding on to for a
sense of
this is me right this is who i am and
and so we have to question so so what
that stirs in people is
questioning well it's who i am who i
really am like oh this is just who i am
i'm just this way but it's who i am who
i really am or is it just who i've been
conditioned to be
and we begin to realize
that the version of ourselves that we
think we are is really just ego and ego
is not good it's not bad it's just a
vehicle
to function in this lifetime that
yeah it's information yeah exactly so it
leads me to the question of
this attracting
the same pattern of a person to
awaken us to our patterns like when we
when we find ourselves in the same
pattern with the relationships or with
work or whatever your sort of trauma and
your places that you're more stuck and
we attract that we actually want the
opposite but we keep attracting what our
pattern is and can you explain that sort
of
mirroring that happens in life to show
us where we're not free
yeah i think we tend to attract that
energetic pattern because inside of us
is also that incomplete energy and so
with that attraction there's an impulse
inside of us
that is seeking
unconsciously seeking to complete what
is not complete from let's say our
childhood or an old relationship and so
we attract often that energy of what's
incomplete and so let's say in
relationships i like to say that we
attract to us a person
people a person whether it's romantic or
not we attract us a person that tends to
be a mirror manifestation
of ourselves we attract to us a person
that mirrors to us our
unresolved issues our unresolved
patterns
those aspects of ourselves that need to
be integrated faced to be healed to be
released to be forgiven to be let go of
and we attract that person in order to
face those parts of ourselves because
ultimately there is no relationship out
there there's really a relationship out
there that's a projection of our own
consciousness within ourselves and so we
are in relationship
in the seeming form of another person
with ourselves
and so i think when we can really see
that oh [ __ ] it's not really anyone out
there because
what we try to do is we point the finger
out there we make it about the other
person we try to change the other person
and we don't change ourselves ego
right whose job
is to
reinforce our existence ego whose
beautiful job is to keep us safe and
protect us from getting hurt again ego
wants everyone else to change
and not to change we want everyone else
to change and not to change and that is
the sort of self-reinforcing mechanism
and intention of ego
because the fear of oh [ __ ] if i change
if i change or my perceived sense of
self-change then who will i be and so
change for ourselves which is why we
resist unconsciously and it's a
beautiful intention change feels like a
a death
to who i am you're letting an aspect of
you that you've held on so tightly to
fall
fall away dissolve yeah
so rumi said in order to be free you
must die before you die
[Music]